Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here in the mountains of
Alaska and I've got a hot tent snow cave
that I've built Six Feet Under the snow
my two boys Tommy and Nate are going to
be joining me tonight and we're gonna
build a killer toboggan run buckle up
this is going to be a great video
[Music]
thank you
all right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right
you can tell I'm getting close you can
see sunlight through the snow maybe a
foot more to go
thank you
I finished digging just in time the sun
just said I need to get a roof on this
thing
oh no oh I made it too wide
foreign
[Music]
I brought my Buffalo hides along we're
gonna have a very warm floor here
let's get this Unholy mess cleaned up
thank you
[Music]
I think I hear somebody
Hey Thomas
oh Nathan my boy's Tommy and Nathan are
gonna join me yay
I'm just trying to get down what do you
guys think is this pretty cool oh this
is sick well should I go say hi to Bob
yeah
yeah give me your smooches
hi Jake how are you doing
Jacob didn't want to come camping with
us today he had to get stitches on his
face yesterday so he's gonna get mommy
snuggles let me look at those stitches
oh yeah right there someone took a toy
to the face yesterday uh we've got some
survival Pizza
thanks for bringing sustenance
I was gonna have dinner ready for the
boys by now but you know sometimes
things take more time than you expect
thanks for coming man be safe you have a
good night with Jacob okay okay love you
take care of our boys love you I love
you
not a lot of trees where we're at so I
had to bring my own firewood so I
decided to bring these fire logs it's a
lot easier to bring one box of these
than try to bring all my firewood
thank you
oh it is so nice in here guys it's warm
I'm not even excited I can feel the heat
you can feel it oh can't you let's get
uh let's get your bed made up
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got the boys bunk beds together but
I'm missing this part it goes right
there here we gotta see if we can fix it
I brought a bunch of this scrap wood to
burn I'm gonna see if I can find
something that will work
that's another
yeah that one maybe
it's a bit Jerry rigged but I think
it'll work so I think that'll work guys
[Music]
what do you think guys is this cozy
all right let's see I'm gonna go get
some water
oh burn my fingers
you got this little water tank for
melting snow on the side of our stove
that's really handy oh you help see that
what the heck
get that yeah sure there you go that was
the vice
anything you look like Thanos with that
huge glove on
this Dave hey guys you want me to start
making some dinner
oh
hey look I'm getting hot how about you
guys Daddy
we got some Fancy Pants dinner planned
for fancy
you know what these are wait
quail eggs
these are not hatching eggs we're gonna
do some Korean barbecue here I have
slices of pork belly that I've marinated
in Colby Korean barbecue sauce
[Music]
it's really hot in your mouth quick huh
yeah we got the quail eggs in there
[Music]
just out we're gonna take all that
grease
here did you grab that you eat some of
that oh
tell me you like it
yeah yep
all right guys we're gonna make some
Japanese ramen
[Music]
we're gonna put some beef steak in your
Ramen okay
I'm gonna do some baby bok choy
okay some green onions
there they go little baby quail egg
you put that in there with that
does that means so um
you know what else we got we got some
mama dofu let me go and Heat this up
got some frozen rice here that looks so
crazy oh it feels so crazy Daddy
that looks good
you guys ready for some Ramen yeah
all right there we go we got ramen Beef
Pork and quail egg
do you guys like the quail eggs yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes
you guys like this the best ramen you've
had so far
oh we both got a pot of babidofu and
some sticky rice here
ground beef onions tofu and a red bean
sauce this is one of Tommy's favorite
foods so when I asked him what food he
wanted me to make on the campout he said
yeah this is actually a Japanese version
of a Chinese dish
you enjoyed the food yeah
good
it's not quite room temperature but it's
certainly a lot warmer than it is
outside definitely the coziest snow
shelter I've ever made you gotta go do
the dishes
you guys all done with dinner yeah you
want dessert I happen to bring a dessert
here do you know what it is cake yes a
Boston cream cake here my wife is
allergic to chocolate so uh when it's
just us boys we have to indulge a little
Columbia
and you can have seconds okay you like
that um pretty good cake is it
don't like the cap out Tom
your own regrets
and Tom would you like to try mine why
not I haven't even used them yet how
tall they are huh
hey puppy peeps I hear all right Mr
puffy feet get into yourself
who wants a body warmer or something
sticky
one right there
Tommy doing okay in there yeah
Nathan you doing good in there yep all
right now we gotta seal up the door
use the sled to seal up the door and
that'll keep any stray breezes out
you guys pretty tired you want me to
read you some bear stories Bears stories
all right we'll do some bear stories get
my boots off get into my bag and I'll
read the story
all right I'm wearing my puffy pants
poor boy
let's find a good beer store here you
want a really scary one really scary one
this chapter is called a boy is blinded
as the bear rushed up to me I turned to
my left defensively he approached knelt
beside me and said Lee I hate to say
this but I don't think you'll ever see
again the next day
foreign
good morning Tommy
good morning do you sleep okay yes
I'm home it's donut time it's donut time
delicious
you got that
well for breakfast would you guys like
some campfire Donuts yeah all right
let's do some campfire Donuts got these
little tube biscuits here sitting by the
fire getting them to thaw out I think
they're frozen solid put some canola oil
in here
okay
all I wanna do today is just sit around
yeah
walls and ice
snow on me hey Tom here
you like that
audio
Nathan why don't you pick one
there you go
look at that oh there we go that's a
perfect one
these little instant biscuits make great
Donuts when they're hot but as soon as
they cool down they kind of just taste
like biscuits again now that we got
breakfast out of the way let's do a
little sledding
look at that beautiful Hill I think that
would make an excellent location for a
toboggan run
all right guys so what we do is we Mark
out the trail with the snowshoes and
then we come back with the shovel and we
make the ramp see how you got these snow
drifts use those as the turns then you
won't have to shovel as much
so you found the tree well didn't you
there you go
oh yeah that's a deep one
I think we got the basic outline done
let's go and build it
foreign
well there we go that is a pretty wicked
looking toboggan run
all right
you want to go first
got your GoPro on we'll play the footage
at your funeral
[Music]
lean back
all right
[Music]
thank you
Wasteland crash
one
[Applause]
oh good job all right
that is a violent to Market ride
I'll tell you what that's one brutal
toboggan run
poor Nathan's feet are cold so I went
ahead and turned the car on got the
heater going we're gonna get him warmed
off are you feeling better
yeah getting snow in your boots stinks
doesn't it alrighty
time to start cleaning up
I just realized that this shelter looks
like Luke Skywalker's home on Tatooine
[Music]
oh Nathan you okay back there
was that toboggan run fine it was fun
and
it's like
[Music]
wait you got no shoes on
yeah
listen I hope you enjoyed this video if
you want to see more videos like this
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
see you guys next Saturday if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching